what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to the rundown where I
basically give you a no frills
explanation on what's going on when it
comes to coming with characters teams so
on and so forth in the realm of comics
now first things first is DC rebirth or
reboot know why in the clock back 1938
Superman first pops up and everybody's
like oh my god this is amazing bullets
are bouncing off of this guy he's
pulling criminals he's even killing a
few folks the popularity of Superman
gave way to Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman
the flash Jay Garrick the Green Lantern
Alan Scott like an army of super heroes
and super villains in DC Comics and the
world was amazing well the problem with
this was of the popularity of
superheroes tied directly into World War
2 and so what's World War 2 began to
come to a close
superhero popularity dropped off
entirely and it was replaced with a
popularity and science fiction
so in 1956 this guy Julius Schwartz
comes along and Julius Schwartz is now
the top dog in DC Comics he's the one
running all the editorial shows and all
that kind of good stuff and Julius
Schwartz says you know what comic books
have been losing popularity for a while
so it's time for us to go ahead and find
a way to reinvigorate interest Q the
very first reboot kind of but not really
in the history of DC Comics Julius
Schwartz goes to all the writers and all
the editors that says you know what give
everybody new origins at the same time
DC reintroduces the flash and the Green
Lantern the difference here is that the
flash is now Barry Allen instead of da
Garrick and the Green Lantern is Hal
Jordan instead of Alan Scott
well then fans are sitting around and
they're like well that doesn't make any
sense if Bruce Wayne is still Batman and
Clark Kent is still Superman Diana
Prince is still Wonder Woman and Arthur
curry is still Aquaman why have the
identities of the Green Lantern and the
flash changed well Julie Schwartz comes
along and says that's a good question
the answer to this question is that this
is a new universe this is a new reality
this is called Earth one the University
you saw before where Alan Scott was a
Green Lantern and Jay Garrick was the
flash that was called earth to cue the
creation of the multiverse fast-forward
over the course of the next 30 years and
the multiverse expands almost
exponentially there are characters from
alternate realities like Power Girl
which is the earth to Supergirl
there's all these different versions of
care
well the problem with this was that by
this point the publications are reaching
into the hundreds the multiverse made
DC's landscapes so convoluted that new
fans had no earthly clue on where to
start they literally didn't know what to
pick up and read so in 1985 this guy
Marv Wolfman comes along and says stop
everything stops we're literally gonna
reboot it all enter crisis on Infinite
Earths now crisis on Infinite Earths was
a great big huge deal because it was the
first time that DC had ever officially
rebooted his continuity at this point
there were an infinite number of
different earths and so the idea was to
take all those different earths get rid
of the characters that were popular keep
the characters that were popular and
then reboot all their origins which is
why the term new earth was originated it
was basically this post crisis on
Infinite Earths continuity that all
these carriers existed on a single
planet referred to as a new earth now
over the course of the next 20 years DC
had two more major crises you had
Infinite Crisis and he went final crisis
to make this easy to understand crisis
on Infinite Earths got rid of the
multiverse Infinite Crisis brought it
back Final Crisis made the heroes aware
of the fact that the multiverse existed
done and done
that should be pretty easy to understand
but during this 20-year period if you
were reading comic books there were
certain characters he would come to
identify with if you were reading the
flash wally west was the only flash
Barry Allen died during crisis on
Infinite Earths and wally west took his
place wally west was in the Justice
League cartoon show these were
characters the kids had grown up with
the reason being that they were able to
identify with these heroes on a personal
level if somebody was running to a
circumstance where they were attending
to live up to a legacy of maybe an older
brother or an older sibling of some kind
they could identify with Wally West
because Wally West was constantly trying
to live up to the legacy that was set
forward by Barry Allen but the fact
remains that people who were reading
comics during this time became extremely
attached to those chemical characters
not only that you had characters like
Hal Jordan the Green Lantern who were
basically garbage until Geoff Johns took
over the title once Geoff Johns took
over the Green Lantern title then it was
amazing because he basically refreshed
everything sure a lot of the history was
there but the difference is that now he
had all these different Lantern cores we
had this great big huge Lantern
mythology it was literally a universe in
and of it
but nonetheless fast-forward to 2011 DC
comes along and says you know what we're
having the same problem that we did with
crisis on Infinite Earths some
multiverses getting really big stories
are getting convoluted people don't
really know where to start so let's just
reboot it all the difference here isn't
almost nobody celebrated a reboot
because people were so vocal and they
were so attached to their heroes that
when new 52 happened
DC got more hatred than they got support
now DC try to correct things they
introduced DC U as a way to basically
have creativity over continuity but the
fact remains that when it came to a
majority of their readers between the
ages of 25 and 44 which is something
like 60 or 70 percent of their reading
base if the information from comics
speed is to be believed most people
hated new 52 and so geoff johns who was
basically a comic book fan writing comic
books became the chief creative officer
of DC and one of the first things he did
is he said we need to go back and we
need to take what works from both the
pre new 52 and the new 52 continuities
and combine them together
enter DC rebirth so the question becomes
this if you're a DC fan what does this
mean for you
well it means that if you really like
Terry McGinnis as Batman Beyond
congratulations he's coming back if you
really want to see the old-school Wally
West before the new 52 where he was the
redheaded Wally West awesome he's coming
back as well and in fact a lot of DC
rebirth centers on him giving us a tour
of everything that's going on but the
most important thing here is that a
fewer fan of the Watchmen and you always
wanted to see the Watchmen appear in the
DC main universe congratulations the
Watchmen are gonna be there and there's
actually this really really cool moment
we basically get this information
telling us that the Watchmen are
watching DC's heroes and the dr.
Manhattan has a really huge role to play
in everything that's been going on but
of course we'll see that unfold as a
series progresses well that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
again there'll be a full explanation
video on DC rebirth sometime in the next
couple days or so once I get it all
fleshed out but for right now I will
catch you guys on her peace